[Music]
hi I'm Stephanie Wong and I work for
Google cloud well I could talk all day
about cloud security physical security
out of Google data center is still
pretty new to me so today I'm on a
mission to learn all about it by taking
an inside look at the systems in place
that protect customer data at a typical
Google Data Center let's go now I've
been told there are six layers of
security here security layer one refers
to the property boundaries and that
includes signage and fencing but things
really start to get interesting when it
comes to layer two also known as the
secure perimeter and that includes the
main entrance gate which I am pulling up
to right now hey how's it going so layer
2 has a lot of security features ranging
from smart fencing to overlapping
cameras to 24/7 guard patrols and more
I'm on my way to meet some experts who
are going to show me how it all works
hi Joe hi Stephanie how are you so I
just passed the main gate and I saw
guards and cameras but what all right
some things that I didn't see yeah
there's actually a lot of technology and
operations going on behind the scene so
from the time that you're on-site we
know that you're here and we're able to
do correlation analysis of where you've
been
we have guards in vehicles we have some
guards on foot there's also the vehicle
crash barrier that's designed to stop a
fully loaded truck from crashing through
the front entrance
riki tree can you tell me more about
what's unique about the fencing this
particular fence is an anticline fence
it's also equipped with fiber that
technology tells us if someone's near
the fence or touches the fence so we use
thermal cameras and standard cameras so
we're able to see video footage at night
just as clearly as we can during the day
[Music]
welcome to layer three building access
just so you know I am still nowhere near
the data center floor that's a few more
layers d let's head inside Stephanie
yeah so you've gotten through the gate
you've come in you're coming to our
secure Lobby you have your card you know
we know that that's you but if someone
happened to lose their card what we want
to make sure is that it's actually
Stephanie who's shown up and with
IRIScan we can authenticate that it's
actually you along with your ID okay I
think it's good one thing that's a
little hard to get used to when you
visit a data center is for secure areas
only one person is allowed to batch
through a door at a time
layer four includes the Security
Operations Center or sock a hive of
activity that is monitoring the data
center 24/7 365 days a year so it sounds
like we've been keeping them very busy
today yes yes you have so the doors the
cameras the badge readers IRIScan
everything is connected here this this
is the brains of the security system so
if there's anything out of the ordinary
happening they have to be able to pick
that up
[Music]
interesting fact about layer 5 the data
center floor less than 1% of Googlers
ever get to set foot in here so right
now I'm feeling kind of special
this is truly a as-needed only access
area meaning that only the technicians
and engineers that have to be there to
maintain upgrade or repair the equipment
are ever allowed there and do Googlers
or anyone have access to the data we
have access to the devices but the data
at rest is encrypted and our customers
can issue and eat their own encryption
keys and we do this because protecting
the privacy and the security of our
users data is our highest priority
the mysterious layer 6 where disks are
erase and destroyed and the fewest
number of people are allowed to enter
drives that need to be retired from the
data center floor come into this room
through a secure two-way Locker system
which means that only technicians
assigned to this room can pull them from
that locker to either erase or destroy
them alright welcome to the crusher room
Wow so at this point we have scanned the
hard drives and the software has told us
that we need to destroy it
here we see it in action backup all
right I'll stay back here
if you didn't think these six layers of
security were enough Google Cloud
actually has two security testing
programs in place one hires companies to
try to break into data center sites from
the outside and the other tasks Googlers
with trying to break security protocols
from the inside and getting out of a
data center is arguably even harder than
getting in as everybody has to go
through full metal detection each time
they leave the data center floor Google
Cloud supports compliance with over 40
global standards regulations and
certifications and the commitment to
constantly test optimize and improve
systems makes it a leader in data center
security now how do we get out of here
[Music]